cadena perpetua para el hombre que ayudó
a un grupo de mercenarios colombianos a
obtener armas para matar al presidente
haitianois en julio de 2021 es la
sentencia que ha determinado un juez
Federal de Miami para rudolf viajar que
cuenta con doble nacionalidad la
haitiana y la chilena y quien ya se
declaró culpable de Conspiración para
cometer asesinato y de brindar apoyo
material para realizar este crimen la
cadena perpetua era el castigo máximo al
que se enfrentaba este hombre que ya
había sido condenado por un narcotráfico
hace 10 años viajar Es una de las 11
personas que han tenido que hacer frente
a la justicia de Estados Unidos por el
asesinato del presidente de Haití Pero
él es el único que se ha declarado
culpable no sé si eso ocurrieron el 7 de
julio de 2021 cuando un grupo de
asaltantes irrumpieron en la residencia
privada del mandatario haitiano en la
capital en Puerto Príncipe en las
autoridades en ese momento arrestaron a
más de 40 personas Incluyendo a 18 ex
soldados colombianos este hombre llegó a
Florida en enero de 2022 después de
haber sido arrestado por las autoridades
dominicanas Y desde ese entonces ha
permanecido bajo arrestos según las
investigaciones en un primer momento se
planteaba la opción de secuestrar al
presidente pero luego cambiaron de
opinión para asesinarlo el objetivo era
acabar con él porque de acuerdo a
documentos judiciales los acusados
pretendían obtener contratos lucrativos
con un nuevo gobierno el resto de
imputados que deberá comparecer ante la
justicia previsiblemente en julio son
dos exmilitares colombianos un arcángel
también colombiano dos ciudadanos
haitianos un estadounidense un
ecuatoriano y un venezolano